every superhero-themed universe needs a
backbone characters that support the
entire universe with their very
existence typically as the story goes
this initial superhero arrives in the
entire world changes with their arrival
be it because of their power their
genius or their morality existing within
12 steps the hero's journey follows the
idea that an individual receives a call
to adventure accept supernatural or
extra dimensional aid and moves from the
threshold of the known to the unknown
following this they encounter some kind
of assistant or sidekick followed by a
mentor face changes on both an emotional
and mental level leading to their death
and rebirth sometimes physical and
sometimes metaphorical their
transformation into the darker self
their atonement and finally they return
to the hero landscape this led to the
first steps of creating the heroic age
of the valiant universe with aliens in
route tune in Jack the mi6 agent joined
the fight first
while ex mi6 agent once he betrayed and
killed his superior because he found out
that he was actually an alien but then
just as it seemed our work was bringing
the heroes together he found himself at
odds with an in Jack and they decided to
fight the aliens in their own ways this
led to our Rick and his local connection
to the vine trying to devise their own
ways to fight against the aliens shortly
after this though the aliens brought the
fight